bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6 et
mélissa mollen dupuis cette semaine on a
une question de carolina qu'on va
l'écouter d'ailleurs pourquoi les kings
prend là un pas que les animaux alors
carolina pourquoi est ce que les inuits
et post malaisie nous y tenez je pense
que beaucoup de programmation utilise la
peau des animaux c'est que autrefois
avant l'arrivée des européens la
majorité de nos vêtements venait
justement de la peau des animaux
on n'avait pas de coton et laine comme
les européens avaient donc la tradition
qu'on avait c'était vraiment lié à
utiliser l'animal ont mangé la viande on
a utilisé les os pour faire des outils
et la peau et la fourrure pour se garder
au chaud
c'est certain que beaucoup de gens
maintenant utilisent plus du tout la
fourrure ou le cuir mais les premières
nations continue justement cette
pratique l'heure parce que on est encore
sur les mêmes territoires et ce sont les
vêtements qui sont souvent les plus
efficaces et les plus résistants pour
nous tenir au chaud dans des
températures très froides
on a des vêtements synthétiques
aujourd'hui mais ses vêtements le zoo
aussi y contribuent à la pollution et
aux changements climatiques donc souvent
c'est de continuer avec des pratiques
traditionnelles qui était de respecter
l'animal et l'animal lui-même
on considère qu'il se donnait à nous et
que si on avait été peu respectueux
qu'on avait gaspillé on n'avait pas bien
fait l'animal refusé de se faire chasser
donc c'est extrêmement important que les
conventionnels mal tout soit utilisée
est encore aujourd'hui se respecte est
la première valeur qui est mis de
l'avant pour les chasseurs inuits et les
premières nations
alors c'est certain que on a beaucoup de
difficultés encore aujourd'hui parce
qu'avec les changements climatiques
ça fait beaucoup plus de tort aux
animaux que la chasse traditionnelle des
premières nations et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on va combattre justement
pourrait aider l'animal est pour lui
montrer le respect puisqu'il nous aide à
survivre sur le territoire depuis des
milliers d'années
alors je suis contente car elle note que
toi aussi tu es encore la vie et la
survie des animaux sur notre territoire
cette belle semaine j'espère que vous
allez partager la question carolina et
j'espère aussi que vous avez nous
envoyer encore des questions à paroles
autochtone